just going to mission
obviously test the mission is to
accelerate the transition to sustainable
energy
so obviously it's incredibly important
that we do that it matters to the world
it matters if it happens sooner or later
it matters if it happens at scale and
that's what the gigafactory is about
it's about being able to make enough
electric cars enough stationary battery
packs that it that it actually moves the
needle from a global carbon production
perspective so that that it actually
does really change the world so that's
that's why it's so it has to be big
cuz the world is big okay that's why so
the crazy thing is like what you're
seeing here is actually only 14% it's
one seventh of what the what the
completed Factory will will be but we've
been able to increase the output of the
factory compared to original design by a
factor of three so ultimately we think
that the factory will produce about 150
gigawatts and we'll talk about about
that yeah so alright so starting with
the you know what is what is this neat
what's needed for the gate batteries the
model 3 so this is really about being
able to make enough uh enough cells
enough batteries to make to make
hundreds of thousands ultimately
millions of electric cars and to do so
at a massive scale
and in a way that is affordable to
people so it doesn't matter it I mean it
well in cars obviously need to be
affordable otherwise you can't but
bloody well buy them so in order to
achieve that there are really two key
dimensions that are necessary one is to
make to keep iterating in technology to
design the technology to be better and
better and have multiple versions and so
this would be our third generation third
major generation of technology and then
economies of scale so we're driving
those to the absolute maximum with with
the gigafactory that's why it's so big
it's big for a reason there just wasn't
enough fact
capacity anywhere else in the world we
didn't have an option you know we this
factory will have the output of all the
lithium-ion factories combined when it's
done yeah yeah yeah exactly the basic
basic math was that in order to make a
half a million cars a year we would need
every lithium-ion battery factory on
earth that makes batteries for phones
laptops cars everything just to to
achieve that bit output so it's like
well clearly that's not being built
because you'd be able to see it on a
satellite picture okay so either either
we figure out some way to build this
thing or there will not be the cars that
that are needed so we kind of just face
that okay we got to just start building
this thing and hopefully hopefully we'll
people buy into it and and you know
start to believe you know that we're
only able to do this because of because
of you guys so it's without without you
this this could not be possible so I
just want to say thank you very much
in order to tucci the sweep we really
had to design the factory as a machine
so the way that people look at factories
is come and it's often thought it was
kind of like a boring thing like making
photocopies or something it's like
warring the select catalog engineering
but this is totally the wrong way to
look at it you really need to look at a
factory like it's a product like it's a
giant machine that builds the machine
and it deserves actually more innovation
and more engineering skill than the
product itself and and that's what we've
done with the Giga Factory yeah we we
have some of our best engineering teams
working on actually laying out the
factory and looking at how to you know
fit more density and more equipment into
the same footprint and this is really
key to how we've been able to reduce the
cost of the cells and the batteries that
come out of here so much you know that
intense engineering effort you know is
what the drives this improvement it's
not just a Zealand set it's not a
copying machine it's not just you know
replicating things that have been done
before we're reinventing that battery
manufacturing process from end to end
yeah in fact I can't emphasize enough
how important this conceptual framework
is because really almost everywhere they
just think of the factory as as a bunch
of machines like not basic machines that
are stuck together to to produce copies
but and and it's mostly pulled from
catalogs you know can't get this machine
from that person that of that at that
company this machine for another company
but but if you applied that same
principle to product design it wouldn't
make any sense like if we try to make
the the Model S out of parts from a
bunch of different cars that it would be
ridiculous you know be like you know a
bumper from a Honda steering wheel from
this of a you know motor from something
else it would look like a print right
exactly it wouldn't make any sense to
actually make a car from bits and pieces
of other cars you really need to design
the car as an integrated product from
the ground up and that's that that's the
same approach we've taken to to the
gigafactory is really really quite
unusual for that to be the case
so yeah and and and then in terms of
analyzing how the factory should work
I'm a big fan of using physics as as a
analytical framework for physics yeah
physics is the physics is physics is
true everything else is debatable and
even physics is questionable so that
that design of the factory from physics
principles means really optimizing the
density of the factory so you can think
like the fundamental efficiency of the
factories is the density of useful stuff
like what percentage of the volume of
the factory is actually useful stuff
versus not useful stuff and then the
output of the factory is the exit
velocity of products from from from the
factory so we're actually just just
applying that throughout or through
every step of the process
we're actually fairly confident that
there's at least maybe a five to ten
fold at least five I think and maybe 10
maybe 10 or more fold a potential
improvement in production capability and
this image you guys can see maybe some
of you can see on the screen is actual
cad of the factory yeah just like you
know just like i'm a great machine the
entire Factory is in CAD you know every
pipe every electrical conduit every
piece of ductwork and every piece of
equipment building the cells so you know
we've modeled all that to fit it in you
know with a LITTLEST the minimum wasted
space everything is basically almost
touching each other on every floor so
you know that was necessary to build
this amazing machine and many factories
aren't done this way they're just you
build a shell and then you sort of
randomly put equipment in there but this
was very different
yeah it's essentially designed like a
very high high-density multi-layer
integrated circuit like an advanced CPU
which is really and actually when you
think about it's like obviously how it
should be should be done and I think
actually over time the manufacturing
process may look a lot like one of those
super fast chip pick-and-place machines
it's super optimized for speed and
density I mean if you think about like
how did we improve the capability of
your phone or your real laptop it wasn't
by making a really giant computer the
size of a table that was by increasing
the clock speed and the density and
those same principles apply to
manufacturing so I'm really excited
about revitalizing manufacturing I think
it's it's sort of it needs love and
we're going to give it
so yeah and we're also expanding the
scope of what people typically thought
of as a battery factory you know we're
going all the way from basic the basic
raw materials that go into making up a
cell you know all the way through to the
finished battery packs under under one
roof in this single factory you know
historically hits go hung between a lot
of different factories yes it's a it's a
three-step process which we've outlined
for you we get all of our secrets are
right here raw material bunch of stuff
happens out comes a car so okay so that
the vertical integration is it's pretty
important because one way to think of
manufacturing efficiency is how long a
journey did that molecule take from when
it was mined so if it was mined in one
part of the world then went to went
halfway across the world to get
processed then back halfway across the
world to get processed another way and
eventually does several trips around the
world before it finally ends up in a
finished product that's obviously just a
[ __ ] like that that's fundamentally
going to be expensive it's like you just
can't send things on round-the-world
trips and expect it to be cheap it's or
affordable it's just not going to not
gonna happen so it makes sense
ultimately for for rail cars of raw
materials to come in one side and then
for finished vehicles to exit the other
side so I mean today we've sort of split
up we've got the vehicle factory in in
Fremont California we've got the the
battery factory here in Nevada but I
think for Giga factory to and beyond I
think we're going to we're just going to
integrate that into one one big facility
and and just to give you a sense of
scale you know that I think you guys
have seen the models you hopefully as
many of you have gone on tours but to
make it sort of more you know more real
this Factory is going to be about six
million square feet of ground area well
that's actually the footprint yeah
just the footprint it'll be the the
biggest building in the world biggest
single building in the world by
footprint and second only in volume to
the the Boeing factory in Washington
State it it's really really huge and if
you sort of think of you know something
that maybe you're familiar with like a
747 that's pretty big right well we can
fit about a hundred 747s parked in the
footprint of this building yeah and I
mean not only that I mean we can fit 50
billion hamsters
so but in terms of vehicles the we
actually expect to get 250 gigawatt
hours a year of output in two years to
give you a sense of of what that size is
total global outputs I don't know the
2015 numbers but the 2014 numbers for
total global output of lithium-ion for
all purposes throughout the world
there's only about 30 gigawatt hours
okay so this is this is more than the
entire planner produced last in 2014
maybe it was episode Li more last year
but still call it roughly figure roughly
this one factory will produce as much as
the rest of the world combined and then
as we get a couple years later perhaps
2020 or there abouts
we expect that the when the practice
fully built out and like said you're
actually standing where you are right
now is the middle of the factory you're
due standing in the middle of where the
factory will be when it's complete so we
should have another party I think
and so when we figure awareness done it
should be able to do on the order of one
and a half million cars and also provide
a lot of power for stationary storage
for battery packs which were obviously
gonna be very important to pair with
solar and all this is happening a lot
faster than we even initially planned it
could you know with the amazing results
from model 3 and we've pulled ahead that
half million cars by you know fully two
years so the building you see outside is
almost doubling in scope you know just
by next year in order to build those
half-million model 3s per year yep so
that's super super exciting I actually
really love manufacturing that's great
it's a like what people should get into
with me part to the master plan so
really there's just this four parts to
it which is to make a beautiful solar
combined with battery storage to expand
to all of the major vehicle segments in
order to as quickly as possible move us
away from oil I get to a self-driving
capability that's about ten times better
than the average driver so then that's a
lot of live saved
so 1.2 million people die a year in auto
accidents so that's a lot of potential
for four lives saved there and then the
ability to add your car to a shared
fleet whenever you want so whenever
you're cause whenever you're not using
your car you'll be able to just tap tap
the Tesla app on your on your phone and
add it to added or subtracted to the
shared fleet and you'll be able to
define like well you know who can use it
like only five-star users or anyone or
only family or whatever and then
whenever you want it back you can just
tap tap it and it will return to you so
so the you know most of time when you
look at cars they're sitting in a
parking lot somewhere and that they're
not being used and this has potential to
massively amplified the utility of
vehicles and offset the cost ownership
and it's Anna's hope
don't be totally up to you when you want
to do it or not do it it's all yours
it will find you will find Pokemon for
you absolutely
horse horse and you know as we said
earlier you know a lot of people you
know really doubted that there would be
enough demand you know to even make a
factory like this make sense in this
timeframe we started this you know way
before the model 3 you know launch event
before we had all those reservations and
you know I think you know it's really a
tribute to all of you guys as customers
that are making this possible so so yeah
really really thank all of you for doing
this
so I mean that that's basically the
overview of the the gigafactory and what
we're up to there's a lot of a lot of
stuff to do already on our plate but um
I think I think we better wrap it up
with that so thank you guys very much
this is all thank you very much really
appreciate it